frisur übt den protest an der gitarre
ein lied des widerstandes es heißt
südamerika ist ein land südlich der usa
[Musik]
das lied beschreibt dass wir hier schon
immer die armen leute waren dass wir
immer nach den gringos kommt dass wir
immer hinter einer elite zurück stimmt
und das war schon immer so wir sind in
einem armenviertel am rand von santiago
de chile
hier leben die verlierer des von großer
ungleichheit und sozialen unruhen
gebeutelten landes und hier zeigt sich
auch wie schwierig der kampf gegen
korona ist obwohl die impfkampagne in
chile so gut läuft wie fast nirgendwo
auf der welt
auch hier werden die menschen getestet
und geimpft corona breitet sich trotzdem
weiter aus weil gerade die ärmsten nicht
zu hause bleiben können sondern geld
verdienen müssen
paulina hat schon beide impfdosen
erhalten nun ist sie wieder zurück in
ihrem täglichen kampf ums überleben
wegen der korona pandemie verlor sie
ihren gut bezahlten job als köchin in
einem casino
ich war chefköchen ich verdiente gut
aber mit all dem was passiert ist habe
ich meinen job verloren
sie haben die casinos geschlossen und
die meisten meiner kollegen sind alle in
der gleichen situation ohne arbeit ohne
ressourcen ohne unterstützung
paulina musste ins armenviertel ziehen
sie lebt in einer hütte die aus zwei
räumen besteht gemeinsam mit ihren vier
enkelkinder
jeden monat muss sie kämpfen um die
miete aufbringen zu können
das ist das einzige schlafzimmer jeder
hat ein bett da ist meins das ist von
den mädchen
und hier ist das badezimmer es fehlen
noch ein paar kleinigkeiten wegen des
geldes komme ich nicht so schnell voran
ein leben ohne abstand drinnen wie
draußen
was anderes kann sie sich nicht leisten
paulina muss unter leute um geld zu
verdienen
sie backt und verkauft empanadas kleine
teigtaschen die pandemie macht die
ärmsten ärmer und schafft so selbst die
bedingungen die ihre bekämpfung
erschweren
die staatlichen hilfen reichen nicht aus
um zu verhindern dass die menschen raus
gehen und arbeiten
wir befinden uns also epidemiologisch in
einem sehr sehr schlechten moment
gepaart mit der ewigen hoffnung dass die
impfstrategie ausgehen möge sketches ist
die leiterin der impfkampagne und im
ganzen land beliebt seit es so gut läuft
doch gerade sie ist es die immer wieder
mahnt geduldig zu bleiben denn bis zur
herdenimmunität sei es noch ein weiter
weg
manchmal kann der im prozess einen
paradoxen effekt erzeugen wenn er
zusammen mit dem druck der wirtschaft
auf die regierungen dazu führt dass
maßnahmen frühzeitig gelockert werden
dabei im chile so schnell wie kaum ein
anderes land mehr als ein viertel der
menschen hat bereits beide impfdosen
erhalten
präsident pinera wird viel kritisiert
wegen seiner neoliberalen
wirtschaftspolitik doch seine
bereitschaft schon vor einem jahr für
viel geld verträge mit den herstellern
der impfstoffe abzuschließen obwohl
unklar war ob sie liefern können macht
sich jetzt bezahlt
auch für marcel sie macht sich auf zum
impfzentrum sie ist 52 und froh dass sie
jetzt an der reihe ist
die impfung soll die viruslast senken
und das ist es wonach wir suchen
niemand ist sicher jeder körper reagiert
anders auf das virus also besser mit
impfstoff als ohne
[Applaus]
marcela gehört zur mittelschicht
schieles sie ist ingenieurin doch das
bedeutet in chile keineswegs sicherheit
zu hoch sind die lebenshaltungskosten zu
groß dass wirtschaftliche abstiegs
risiko und so will auch sie mit uns
lieber über die soziale schieflage im
land reden als über corona oder ihre
impfung
wir wollen dass alle menschen zu ihrem
recht kommen dass die menschen
entschieden gleichgestellt werden
das land ist sehr gespalten was den
wohlstand und die möglichkeiten angeht
das ist eine ganz andere pandemie die
wir lange vor dieser haben zwei pandemie
in beuteln das land und befruchten sich
gegenseitig wachsende ungleichheit und
cupid die sozialen unruhen in chile
brechen aus im herbst 2009 10
was als protest gegen erhöhte u bahn
tickets beginnt entwickelt sich zu einem
blutigen konflikt gegen ein als
ungerecht empfunden es kapitalistisches
system
die regierung gibt schließlich nach und
verspricht eine neue verfassung durch
corona hat den prozess unterbrochen
geblieben sind gegenseitiges misstrauen
und angst vor einer erneuten eskalation
und das behindert zusätzlich die
eindämmung der pandemie jede regel die
der stadt erlässt steht unter dem
verdacht auch ein mittel zur politischen
unterdrückung zu sein und so verführt
der erfolg beim impfen die regierung
dazu die unpopulären lockdown maßnahmen
zu schnell zu lockern
die folge ist der erneute anstieg der
infizierten trotz dieser impfung chile
kann ein gutes beispiel dafür sein dass
andere länder in der welt mit vorsicht
öffnen sollten und nicht den gleichen
fehler machen wie wir nämlich
lockerungen zu überstürzen und damit
eine pandemie zu entfesseln die zu
vielen todesfällen führt das virus ist
auf dem vormarsch wie nie zuvor
entschieden
die krankenhäuser sind voll santiago
befindet sich wieder im lot
maria ist krankenschwester auf der
intensivstation seit beginn der pandemie
hat sie sich von ihrer familie isoliert
um sie zu schützen
das einsame sterben der opfer die
arbeitsbelastung das allgegenwärtige
virus gehen nicht spurlos an ihr vorüber
es berührt mich aber mit wem kann ich
das teilen wenn es meinen kollegen
genauso geht
zu hause ist sie allein mit ihrer last
kraft gibt ihr eine collage mit fotos
ihrer familie
andere menschen haben auch verwandte die
ihnen so wichtig sind
deswegen macht meine arbeit einen
unterschied ich rette menschen damit
niemand jemand er in seiner collage
verliert doch so wie maria nicht aufgibt
ist auch das virus nicht leicht klein zu
kriegen
chile ist ein vorbild beim impfen aber
zugleich eine mahnung im kampf gegen
korona nicht locker zu lassen